centromias are the constriction in a
mitotic chromosome it divides the
chromosome into two halves p and Q arms
centromere has specific characteristics
it has very compact DNA but how it is
extremely compact because it has
specific post translational
modifications and unique histone
variants like samp a centromere based on
its position can classify chromosome
into different types like metacentric
where the centromere is at the Middle
submetacentric where the centromere is
little bit away from the Middle
acrocentric where the centromere is
pretty much closer to the end and
telocentric where the centromere is at
the end
based on other classifications there
could be it they could be divided into
Regional centromeres and they can be
divided into Point centromeres which are
mostly found in budding East watch full
video to know more